here we
go buyers said no way to woke lingerie
true they suffered a financial blow when
they put panties on Megan
rapo Victoria sret is apparently
ditching their woke Rebrand of recent
years after it didn't translate to
financial success the company said they
lost money on unsold merch and the yards
of fabric needed to make plus-sized
panties also they added that some of the
new models were so chubby they couldn't
see their own
penises the lerie Brand's makeover
efforts included making Magan and trans
model Valentina seneo F spokes models as
well as getting rid of their famous
Angels but their chief executive told
investors last week quote despite
everyone's best Endeavors it's not been
enough to carry the day W who could have
told you that you idiot so they're
returning to what works hot models
recent campaigns featured Haley Bieber
and Emily Rakowski and of course their
newest
sensation
yeah yeah looks like my diet's really
paying
off Larry when you look at all these
major business catastrophes whether it's
Bud Light or it's Disney or just generic
sports teams CNN Victoria Secret they
all abandoned their core Mission yeah
for wokeism what are they going to able
to regain any of their share no it's
going to be real hard look this is Bud
Light onone wrong same story again this
is Disney gone wrong these are companies
that don't know their own customer base
I mean you're asking me a business
question not a sex related question yes
that'll come later I'm very pleased to
answer it in these terms
and and it's maybe they can climb back
maybe they can't but you know the
history of this thing is once you make
that uh move once you desert your
customers you're finished yes I will
never do that here we'll never abandon
poop jokes
thank you number one show in late night
all due to poop Charles do you see this
as a larger Trend are companies going to
start waking up that realizing that the
woke can ruin them I think companies
where the founder is still relatively
involved uh I think the ones that have
been around for a long time like the
Disneys of the world were Executives who
went to Harvard you know they have no
real true connection you talk about
roots in fact it's really interesting if
you think about like the most farle
companies they're all at San Francisco
all with these leftwing Founders and
these these guys who go to these
colleges and they just listen to
Consultants do you know Disney stock is
at a nine-year low a nyear low they were
supposed to make a fortune off of you
know when we got out of the pandemic on
the on the uh thing make a fortune
deserve every deserve every minute of it
it's nuts Disney deserve everye nuts so
you know what there's little
accountability the CEO still makes $46
million a year so no one's saying
anything but when the family is still
closely associated there's time to fix
it yeah you know Tyrus I'm a little
bummed because I was looking forward to
seeing Leah Thomas and a bikini and
angel
wings
don't don't don't don't just
don't you know you wanted two Fox
Business guys on so this didn't turn
into a sex story no he he he no he
wanted two Fox Business guys to turn it
into a sex you you know not what he does
I know him wish I had an apple right now
what you want bro
um this is what they did was is and I
think most guys would agree with me men
don't care about lingerie we all you
could be in sweatpants and we got a
solid yes that night we're good we don't
care we're just excited we're getting to
go to the dance women bought lingerie
for themselves and their girlfri they
show their girlfriend how does this look
and like they it's their thing it was
their thing and you spit in the face of
women which seems to be the easiest
thing to do and now thanks to the
protest we know what a woman is again uh
we can get back to Victoria Secrets was
for women and that whether it was
plus-sized women or whatever they went
away from all that they took all their
jobs away they changed the style they
they made it weird and and creepy and
you had chubby guys with beards and blue
thongs nobody want to see that I know
they were shocked and no one want to see
that no one wants to see any big guy in
the thong you know what I'm saying it's
not our thing we get by with Charisma
and power yeah so they went and they did
that and they messed up horribly they
blew it and to Charles point the own
like Hey we're not making money I had no
gas for my yacht yeah so we got to
change some things thank you for being
different but you and your unicorn
stripe tattoo face got to go we need to
make some money I mean and real quick
Disney bought Marvel they bought Star
Wars they made big moves they were
changing everything the Disney Channel
they were going to take over the world
and they're worse with all their
Acquisitions now they bought a bunch of
stuff that nobody wants so look real
soon for a Victoria Secrets clearance
sale with a Disney crossover
coming cat uh are um oh jeez I was going
to ask an inappropriate question what I
was hoping you would so that I could get
rich are you going to are you going to
give Victoria Secret another chance when
they when they stopped you still are
technically asking me where I'm going to
buy my underwear
yes I get miney off eBay that's good I
think really good I think that's
actionable you caught him you caught him
I did yes great this is when you come
out as non-binary
exactly okay coming out I always have
been Victoria's Secret I just want to
correct what several people have said
here it was never woke it was never woke
just like how if a guy's really nice to
you and then he stops talking to you and
he realizes you're not going to have sex
with him he was never never a nice guy
he just wanted to have sex with you
right they thought this would make it
money and then they didn't all they ever
want is money so you shouldn't fall for
it when companies do this because they
they just want money at the end of the
day well your point is well taken in the
sense that they were doing the woke
stuff to cover up for any kind of greed
that they have most companies do the
woke stuff to keep the activist off
their back right absolutely but it's
performative it's performative and
problematic all right hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else